bonjour régine délais bonjour monsieur
via le temps hier le recteur pascal jean
à ce micro ce matin l'une des voix
syndicales de l'enseignement avec le
snuep-fsu dans le premier degré le
premier degré des écoles primaires à
l'origine délais les professeurs d'école
ont fait leur rentrée hier en attendant
les élèves ce matin une rentrée
2018-2019 sous quels auspices pour vous
alors cette rentrée pour nous en tout
cas pour les personnels ne pouvons pas
dire que c'est une rentrée sereine pour
la bonne raison que nous avons encore
beaucoup de collègues qui n'ont pas reçu
leurs arrêtés d'affectation
ça veut dire quoi concrètement ce que
des personnes officiellement non pas
leurs décisions alors arrêté pour se
rendre sur leur poste
que va-t-il donc se passer est ce que ce
sont des collègues qui rompt en toute
illégalité dans les écoles réclamer des
postes ou tel poste
ou alors on est sérieux et on donne
comme il se doit
l'arrêté d'affectation pour être nommé
sur un poste
ils sont combien au dernier recensement
nous avions 170 collègues qui étaient
sans affectation
alors là il faut procéder manuellement
au aux arrêtés à la rédaction d arrêter
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya au bas mot
170 collègues qui sont en attente de
leur arrêté il ya des directeurs d'école
qui n'ont pas eu leurs arrêtés vous vous
imaginez une école qui va commencer et
là je suis vraiment tu m'avais imaginée
par luc enjeux de simple disons retard à
l'allumage mais alors nous pourrions
penser que ce n'est qu'un retard
sauf que cela se répète d'année en année
alors nous avions des surnoms au fur et
à mesure en dents dans la gestion du
mouvement mais là nous avons vraiment
touché le fond et lavandières au recteur
il faut vraiment se pencher sur la
gestion du personnel la gestion du
mouvement des enseignants on ne peut pas
imaginer que des enseignants ne sache
pas aujourd'hui sur quelque la star
quelle école ils sont attendus
j'avais cru comprendre que de rentrée
scolaire se préparait des semaines des
mois al avance alors on vous savez vous
avez peut-être suivi que nous étions
montés au créneau sur la façon dont vous
les gels et le rectorat martinique sur
le dédoublement de cp cp on respirait
plus et puis c'est un
il a fallu tout refaire au mois de juin
au mois de mai il a fallu tout refaire
donc forcément ça a créé donc c'est
contraire à tard c'est tout simplement
contexte et nous aurions aimé que ce
soit contre x entretien l'an dernier
l'année d'avant cap21 17 juillet
mouvement mobilité des enseignants non
ça nous nous y sommes malheureusement
pas habitués mais ça n'est plus rare et
c'est vraiment décevant que kylie a
autant d'attentes au niveau de cette de
notre hiérarchie que pour que nous
soyons aussi maltraités que vos réponses
que vous répond que vous répondez
services du rectorat
bien sûr on va me donner les mêmes
raisons on vous savez nous avons pris du
retard
d'accord mais pendant cette rentrée ne
s'est pas n'est pas préparé donc le
rectorat va répondre quoi qui met tout
en oeuvre pour pour régulariser les
situations mais c'est juste pas normal
que le jour de la rentrée des élèves
bord du sea quelques jours tout sera
réglé
quinze jours trois semaines ou un mois
ça a déjà pris beaucoup plus de temps
que ça pour certains enseignants jean
baylet cette année arrive avec son lot
de nouveautés vous l'avez évoqué
notamment le dédoublement des classes en
rp en réseau d'éducation prioritaire
le système va s'amplifier c'est une
bonne chose pour les petits martiniquais
du cours préparatoire et du cours
élémentaire 1
alors la mesure n'est pas nouvelle
il faut l'expérimenter avec les
dispositifs qui sont prévus donc
dédoublement allègement de cp une
évaluation bon faudra aussi compter la
formation bon le professionnalisme devra
aussi compter sur le professionnalisme
des équipes qui sont déjà en place
par contre le bémol dans cette
dans ce nouveau dispositif c'est que
tous les mètres supplémentaires dont
nous disposions jusque-là pour la
différenciation en français en
mathématiques ou d'autres d'autres
disciplines tous ses personnels à ne
sont plus mobilisés parce qu'ils ont
tous été réaffectés sur les cp ce1
ça veut dire quoi concrètement qu'on
aura des classes à faible effectif on cp
ce1 et que pour les autres niveaux nous
aurons beaucoup plus d'élèves
elle est au-dessus de la moyenne la
moyenne est pas énorme et l'état 20
accords 20 22 on pourra avoir des
effectifs en 25 en amont et en aval dans
les niveaux de grande section et au
niveau de cm1 cm2 et pour ces niveaux là
qu'ils seront un peu plus chargé 1 par
rapport à 12 par rapport à 15
un peu plus chargé il n'y aura plus ce
personnel mobilisables pour venir en
aide aux élèves d habiller paul
oblige complètement 48 mètres
supplémentaires jusqu'à maintenant poste
complètement fermée pour les
redistribuer voile et la mesure du
gouvernement phare pour qu'ils ne
bénéficier d'aucun moyen supplémentaire
donc on a récupéré des besoins on a
récupéré les moyens de notre succès
le rôle de ces postes supplémentaires et
le rendement de ces postes
supplémentaires c'est évaluer très peu
par contre sur le terrain les collègues
peuvent vous dire ils ont l expérimenté
pendant deux ans ils peuvent vous dire ô
combien seul ça fait du bien
d'accord il s'agit calcul mieux on lit
mieux comprend mieux les choses dans ce
mirror lorsqu'on a un poste de maître
supplémentaires on accorde du temps à
l'élève on accorde du temps elles
élèvent pour s'attarder à ces
difficultés lui proposer un rythme qui
lui conviennent parce qu'il ne s'agit
pas de faire rentrer tout le monde dans
le même rythme encore une fois c'est ce
qu'on veut nous faire porter on va mais
tellement de ces pv au bout de l'année
tout le monde saura lire qu'à des
prérequis et ont fait pas boire de l'eau
si on n'a pas soif
d'accord donc là il faut doit pas
s'attendre à un faudra bien mettre la
pression pour les collectes mesure les
collègues pour que tous 6h les ans si
les pré requis ne sont pas mis
si les élèves ont des difficultés par
ailleurs enregistreurs on reviendra sur
la pression
les exercices sur le dos de vos
collègues
revenons sur quand même quelques mesures
annoncées pour cette rentrée 2018 2019
l'interdiction des téléphones portables
dans le primaire également c'est une
bonne chose pour vous au niveau du
primaire nous expérimentons pas cette
difficulté d'élèves qui viennent avec
des portables ont peut-être au niveau
des cm2 ça peut arriver mais franchement
c'est très très rare et ça reste les
textes disent que c'est pour favoriser
la vie sociale au sein même de
l'établissement pour éviter par exemple
le racket absolument niveau 2 du cm2
c'est complètement cessé complètement
vrai au niveau du collège aussi ça peut
évidemment conforté la sécurité bon
parce que ça on attire les convoitises
quand on est désormais rappelez-vous aux
abords d'un certain collège
un étude on élève qui s'était fait
racketter il compte une fois que ça
m'est pas aux primaires pas aux
primaires alors l'anglais plus le cycle
3 pour faciliter le passage du cm2 la
sixième le plan mercredi
quoi d'autre par exemple l'expression
orale tout ça ce sont des mesures qui
vont dans le bon sens des choses ce sont
des mesures qui sont déjà
alors pour pour l'expression orale libre
c'est une actrice et une pratique dès la
maternelle c'est une pratique donc que
ce concours que le recteur demande que
ce soit formalisée bon c'est une
pratique là on n'innove pas sur les
mercredis en là encore un
il s'agit de solliciter on va dire les
volontaires pour faire fonctionner les
32 min 33 communes sur 34 compte accepté
de passer à la semaine de quatre jours
en martinique
oui parce que ben justement pour
permettre de proposer à des élèves des
activités autres un des activités
sportives qui ne pourraient pas se payer
forcément il faut d'une organisation
pense que le ce que voulait monsieur
peillon s'était proposé des activités à
tous les élèves
maintenant il a proposé s'assure du
temps scolaire même temps bon c'est pour
l'instant la place du mercredi 6 et
reste voilà offrir des activités à
l'ensemble des élèves
oui il faut y réfléchir maintenant il ya
des animateurs sportifs
il faut il faut il faut y penser il faut
pas simplement sollicité que les bonnes
volontés
il faut aussi les ans les encadrants et
spécialisés il faut les payer
oui il faut les payer ça pose problème
revenons maintenant sur l'état d'esprit
de l'enseignement du premier degré
comment se portent un enseignant en
martinique lorsqu on enseigne de la
maternelle jusqu'au cm2 jusqu'au cm2
j'aurais envie de vous dire que
l'enseignant il s'accroche et s'accroche
à ses convictions il s'accroche à son
métier il s'accroche aux savoirs à faire
acquérir ce à dire que il est au coeur
du système
ce n'est pas très bien valorisé mais il
s'accroche quand bien même toutes les
difficultés vous que qui ne sont
inconnus du grand public
quand bien même ils ont à gérer les
difficultés d'affectation de de
régularisation de leurs indemnités de
leur gestion de leur carrière de look ou
de leurs congés etc
ils sont en poste par contre le
gouvernement et les injonctions que nous
recevons font que nous sommes fatigués
au bout d'un certain temps on arrive au
beurre en art il n'est pas reconnu comme
maladie professionnelle
être chez l'enseignant est liée à un
mal-être chez les enseignants il faut le
savoir il faut le dire ce n'est pas de
la faiblesse 1 il y a à force de
demander de changer de programme de
changer les réformes de demander
d'entrer et de faire est de faire au
bout d'un moment on fait mais ne sont
pas des robots
comment faire pour rétablir dans avec
comme objectif le succès de l'élève
comment faire pour rétablir cette
confiance vis-à-vis des enseignants
quand comment créer un climat d'entente
et de respect c'est exactement monsieur
meudon ce que je voudrais qu'on arrive à
à souhaiter à nos collègues dans l'école
de la confiance il faut que ce que cela
arrive à tous les niveaux
respect entente confiance ça passe par
le dialogue ça passe par le dialogue à
tous les niveaux requis entre parents
enseignants équipe dirigeante et que
mais comment me disant équipe dirigeante
nom passant à ceux qui sont au plus haut
en plus haut lieu qui décide
doté de vie bien sûr il faut laisser la
porte ouverte faut continuer à dialoguer
sur la passion du dialogue il y à du
dialogue monsieur le reste monsieur le
recteur dialogue et présente ses projets
il reste à l'écouté mais il a quand même
ses projets à même et donc ils dessinent
temps qu'il décide de les appliquer en
informe d'abord avant d'appliquer
merci jean baylet d'avoir été avec nous
rappelle que vous êtes du syndicat
snuipp fsu merci à leur donner la parole
aussi bfs martinique